“In the autumn of 1918, as the empire for
which they had fought was collapsing around
them, weary soldiers of the Habsburg imperial
and royal army made their way back to their
homelands.
For some of the higher Habsburg officers,
however, the dissolution of the old Austro-Hungarian
empire created a unique dilemma.
Some of them had spent so many years as servants
of the emperor, and had grown so accustomed
to the international flavor of the Habsburg
military life, that they found it difficult
to switch their loyalty to any of the new
nation states that were arising from the ruins
of the old empire … In the days after the
armistice, these disoriented men, for whom
the future seemed particularly bleak and uncharted,
gravitated to Vienna, there to pay their final
tribute to Karl, the last reigning ruler of
the six hundred year old dynasty.”
One of these men, who appeared in Vienna for
his last audience with the emperor was none
other than the Rear-Admiral Miklos Horthy,
the Commander in Chief of the Habsburg Navy.
During his last audience with the Emperor,
Miklos Horthy, trembling and with tears in
his eyes, vowed that “I will never rest
until I have restored your Majesty to his
throne in Vienna and Budapest”.
Who, however, was this 50 year old admiral
called Miklos Horthy, where did he come from,
and did he eventually fulfill his promise
to the emperor?
Well, let's find out.
But before we do.
This video is part of a greater Historytuber
collaboration called Project Dictator where
multiple historytubers talk about the history
behind various people that have been called
dictators, or tyrants or similar in the past.
If you want to see all those videos head on
to the Project Dictator playlist, link in
the top right corner, description and pinned
comment.
Biography of Miklós Horthy
Miklos Horthy was born in 1868 to low nobility
in the Hungarian town of Kenderes.
His father was a member of the Hungarian parliament,
and, overall, his family, even though low
nobility, wasn’t poor by any means and controlled
around a 610 hectare estate.
Miklos Horthy was not neglected by his parents
but he was one of 8 children and in such an
environment his parents’ attention was often
divided.
This, combined with Horthy’s “desire for
adventure”, meant that at his own behest,
Horthy was sent to multiple boarding schools
first in Debrecen and later in Sopron.
When Horthy was 14, his older brother was
accidentally killed during a naval exercise
in the Royal Naval Academy, after this unfortunate
accident, Horthy decided that he wanted to
follow in his late brother's footsteps, and
enrolled in the "Imperial and Royal Naval
Academy" in today’s Rijeka.
Here, just like in his previous schools at
Debrecen and Sopron, Horthy showed average
ability in almost all his subjects but one,
languages.
He seemed to have a knack for learning new
languages and quickly, on top of already knowing
French, German and Hungarian, picked up full
fluency in Italian, and Croatian.
Once he graduated, and officially joined the
Navy, Horthy would also learn a sundry of
other languages most notably English which
he learned while stationed in Pola.
His English teacher in Pola was, at the time,
an unknown poor writer called James Joyce.
While stationed in Pola Horthy also learned
how to sing and play the piano thanks in part
to the local Royal Navy band leader, Franz
Lehar.
Horthy seemed quite content with his place
in the navy and very much enjoyed the opportunities
the navy provided, especially the ability
to see the world and meet new people.
He traveled as a naval liaison to far flung
places like the Ottoman Empire, New Zealand,
India, Borneo, Portugal, England, etc.
Everywhere he went he was always enthusiastically
welcomed by the local high society not only
because of his language and conversation skills,
and his reputation as a perfect victorian
gentleman, but also because of his dancing,
music, and athletic skills.
He was an avid fencer, equestrian, and a tennis
player.
During his travels Horthy also developed great
admiration for the British Royal Navy stating
“the proud saying … ‘Britannia rules
the waves’ prevailed; we have seen many
profound examples of this throughout our journey.”
Due to Horthy’s experiences abroad, his
excellent language and social skills, and,
his competence when it came to actual naval
command, he steadily climbed up the carrier
poll in the Royal Navy.
Most notably becoming the naval advisor to
the Emperor Franz Joseph in 1909 at the age
of 41.
It was here, in Vienna, where Horthy was introduced
to the inner workings of the Empire and formulated
many of his conservative monarchist political
ideas.
Vienna during that time was apparently the
place to be as not just Horthy and Franz Joseph
lived in Vienna but also Hitler, Tito, Stalin,
Trotsky, Freud, and many others.
If you want to know more, I made a video about
it.
When the Great War started, Horthy, now 46,
was a commander of SMS Habsburg, but this
was only the beginning.
One historian described Horthy’s rise through
the ranks during the 4 year period of the
Great War as “meteoric”.
He proved his naval skills early on during
several naval encounters in the Adriatic sea,
and on top of being given a myriad of Austro-Hungarian
military awards, he was even awarded the German
Iron Cross both first and, second class, in
1915, due to his successful efforts of escorting
German U-Boats through an entente blockade.
In 1917 he planned, led, and successfully
executed an entire operation which resulted
in the largest WW1 naval battle in the Adriatic
sea, the Battle of the Otranto Strait.
During the battle Horthy was outnumbered and
wounded, but continued to issue orders for
hours until he eventually collapsed from blood
loss.
He was praised all throughout the Empire as
a war hero, especially by Hungarians who viewed
him as the most notable Magyar of the Great
War.
Due to all this Horthy was appointed as the
Commander in Chief of the Habsburg navy in
1918.
This new command would not last long as sadly
for Horthy, the war ended with the breaking
up of the Empire into a myriad of national
components.
Horthy would later recall that surrendering
the Habsburg Navy to the entente, along with
all the other events that occurred in central
Europe after the war, were one of the saddest
moments of his life.
The empire he served his entire life was destroyed
and the country which he was supposed to call
home was beset by enemies on all sides ready
to divide its territory.
Horthy, however, was not a politician and
after his last meeting with the emperor returned
to his family estate in Kenderes where, as
Thomas Sakmyster puts it, “He no doubt hoped
to spend his remaining years as a country
squire far removed from the political machinations
of Budapest and Vienna.”
But fate had other plans.
In early 1919, the Hungarian government resigned
in protest against the entente demands.
The ensuing power vacuum was exploited by
the Hungarian communists who seized power
and established the Hungarian Soviet Republic.
With the rise of Hungarian communism Horthy
suddenly became directly affected by the politics
he hoped to avoid.
Biography of Miklós Horthy : The Fellowship
of the Counter-Revolution
The establishment of the Hungarian Soviet
Republic was, for Horthy, like a bad dream.
He, and many of his fellow landholders of
the old aristocracy, suddenly became targets
of the communist government and his brother
was even briefly imprisoned in Budapest.
The peasants in the Kenderes area were on
multiple occasions urged by the communists
arriving from Budapest to seize the estates
and manor houses of the local nobility and
rise up against their oppressors including
Horthy and his family.
We do not have any details of what exactly
might have happened in Kenderes during this
time or how much was Horthy and his family
affected by some radicalized peasants swept
up in the communist fervor.
However, it is safe to assume that some confrontations
between the peasants and the landowners did
occur during this time in Kenderes.
The rise of the Hungarian Soviet Republic
also brought about a rise in targeted executions
and acts of terorrism against people deemed
as enemies of communism.
These killings and terrorist acts became to
be known in Hungary as the Red Terror.
The antagonism of his own peasants combined
with the red terror sweeping across the country
made Horthy despise the communists and everything
they stood for.
It was also at this time that Horthy, along
with many other counterrevolutionaries, came
to formulate quite strong antisemetic ideas
mostly spurred on by the fact that a lot of
the Hungarian communists happened to be of
jewish origin.
For example, the leader of the Soviet Republic,
Bela Kun, and 20 of his 26 commissars, were
all of jewish origin.
The exact reasons for this fairly large involvement
of jews in the Hungarian Soviet Republic are
still being debated by historians today but
it is prudent to mention that numbers wise
jews were still a minority and most Hungarian
communists were ethnic Hungarians.
Nonetheless, Horthy, as a believer in old
Habsburg monarchist ideas, viewed Bela Kun,
and his quote “jewish” Soviet Republic,
as the most dangerous movement ready to destroy
the Hungarian way of life.
For Horthy, Kun, and his government, was even
more dangerous to Hungary than the neighboring
countries taking over Hungarian land.
So, when, in the spring of 1919, Horthy, the
most notable Hungarian war hero, received
a letter from a counterrevolutionary government
forming in Szeged if he wanted the command
of the newly created “National Army”.
Horthy, wanting to put an end to the Hungarian
Soviet Republic and maybe reconquer back some
of the lost Hungarian lands, enthusiastically
accepted this offer and arrived in Szeged
30 of May 1919.
During his first cabinet meeting of the counter
revolutionary government Horthy proclaimed
“I couldn’t sit in Kenderes listening
to the grass rustling in the wind, when my
poor fatherland lise in ruins.
It has been a difficult inner conflict, but
I have come.
I accept the responsibility.
I am at your command.”
Horthy’s first and only task was to form,
organize, and train the “National Army”.
This, unsurprisingly, proved to be a very
difficult task with mixed results.
Due to the ongoing wars between the Hungarian
Soviet Republic, Czechoslovakia, and Romania,
Horthy could only muster up men from the local
area.
For more context on the history of post war
Hungary watch my Dissolution of Hungary video.
As a result of these circumstances, by July,
Horthy had only around 5k men.
However, despite these small numbers, Horthy’s
story started to circulate throughout the
entire country.
This story presented a man, a leader, who
would often entertain the men in the pub by
singing and playing the piano, by sharing
anecdotes of far flung lands he visited, by
telling war stories of maritime adventures.
Here was a war hero, an aristocrat of the
old regime who, to the common soldiers, seemed
like one of them.
It did not matter, even to the most fervent
nationalists, that Horthy’s Hungarian was
quote “simple”, spoken with a German accent,
and often intermixed with German or even English
words and phrases when Hungarian ones didn’t
come to mind.
That merely added to the international character
of this national hero who clearly spent a
long time away from Hungary but has now come
home to liberate it, to raise it to greatness.
These early post-war months were the very
beginnings of what came to be Horthy’s leader
cult.
However, not all Hungarians saw in him a hero.
Many workers living in larger cities viewed
Horthy as an old aristocrat who was content
with the status quo and, therefore, will bring
no change, no glory, and no prosperity to
the struggling country.
When it came to the politicians of the counter
revolutionary government who invited Horthy
to lead the army.
They saw in him nothing more than a military
figurehead whose popularity could be used
to form an army and establish a new government.
They certainly did not expect Horthy to meddle
in the political side of the counterrevolution
and initially they were right.
Horthy seemed to have been very apathetic
towards politics and often just quietly did
his duties as the commander of the national
army.
This national army, during the summer of 1919,
began to attract ever more radicalized right-wing
extremists.
Many of the men joining the army were Hungarians
driven from their homes by either Hungarian
Communists or hostile governments of Czechoslovakia,
Romania and Yugoslavia.
These men underwent the “radicalizing effects
of the refugee experience” and held fierce
nationalistic, anti-semetic, anticommunist,
militaristic, and iridentist ideas.
The most prominent of these right-wing extremists
were within the officer core.
People like Gombos, Kozma, Ostenburg, Pronay,
etc.
These people were also the ones that spent
the most time with Horthy as his army advisors
and, therefore, could stoke within him ever
more radical right-wing beliefs.
Horthy wasn’t opposed to this and, as stated
before, he already fostered his own antisemetic,
anticommunist, and irredentist feelings, but
it was in Szeged where he began to be far
more radicalized then before.
In his own words “I am now capable of anything
… if necessary, I’ll use strychnine poison
and employ the basest methods.
After all, our enemies have treated us like
corpses to be desecrated.”
Since Horthy had become quite radicalized
at this point it was not unsurprising that,
when his officers like Pronay started to assassinate
political opponents and jews in and around
Szeged, he turned a blind eye to all these
killings.
Even when the politicians in the counter revolutionary
government started to pressure Horthy to stop
the killings, Horthy did nothing.
In fact, he even praised Pronay and appointed
him as his personal bodyguard.
Then, in August of 1919, the Hungarian Soviet
republic fell to the Romanian advance and
the counter revolutionary government sprung
into action.
The National Army numbers started to steadily
rise and the counter revolutionary government
quickly sent out parts of this growing national
army to western Hungary in order to take control
of it.
The leaders of this expedition were the radical
right-wing officers like Pronay and Mikos
Kozma who stated that “Both the red and
the pink eras are over … Those who for months
have committed heinous crimes must receive
their punishment.
It is predictable … that the compromisers
and those with weak stomachs will moan and
groan when we line up a few red rogouse and
terrorists against the walls.
Once before the false slogans of humanism
and other ‘isms’ helped drive the country
into ruin.
This second time they will wail in vain.”
Horthy’s orders to the departing officers
were only given verbally and there’s no
record surviving that could tell us what those
orders were.
However, it is almost certain that Horthy
knew the intentions of his officers and that
he himself chose to send these specific men.
He was more than aware of what these radicalized
men were planning to do and we have to assume
that’s what he wanted as in the end he was
the one who sent them.
There is even a quote surviving from Horthy’s
chief of staff Karoly Soos who told Pronay
before leaving “Don’t kill too many jews,
since that will create problems too.”
With their orders in hand and their minds
made up the radical right-wing officers of
the national army went on a campaign of what
they called “purification” in mostly western
hungary.
The majority of the national army, mostly
the lower rank consrcipts, did not take part
in the heinous crimes and killings of jews
and people who were suspected of having communist
sympathies even when there was no proof; but
a substantial number of the officer core of
the army did conduct these crimes which became
to be called the White Terror.
As Horthy was working on retaking Budapest
from the Romanian occupation, newspapers started
to publish the stories of the white terror
happening all accross western Hungary.
When these reports reached Horthy and the
people around him he did nothing and simply
just dismissed the news.
Then when Pronay returned to Horthy, Horthy
told him to “continue the excellent job
he has been doing”.
Even when Hungarian politicians and entente
ambassadors started to put ever more pressure
on Horthy to stop the White terror Horthy
still remained silent on the whole issue.
Hearing out the concerns of the politicians
and the entente ambassadors but not doing
anything about it.
There is no evidence to prove or disprove
that Horthy ever directly ordered or participated
in any of the executions of the White Terror
but he certainly intially did not stop it,
or even tryed to stop it, despite clearly
being aware of it happening.
Meanwhile the political situation in Hungary
had gotten complicated.
The Szeged government disbanded, a new counter
revolutionary government was founded in Budapest
after the communists fled, another counter
revolutionary government was coming from Vienna,
and “there were multiple local governments
and strongmen who exerted control across the
occupied lands of Hungary.”
When the Szeged government fell apart Horthy
found himself at the head of an ever growing
National Army which was now without a government.
Despite this, Horthy continued on as normal
as if nothing happened and was getting his
national army ready to retake Budapest after
the Romanians were ordered by the entente
to withdraw.
This caused a lot of concern for many Hungarian
politicians from the various counter revolutionary
governments.
After all Budapest was the city which enthusiastically
supported the communists, still had many communist
sympathizers, and had a large jewish population.
Therefore, many politicians were afraid of
what the National Army could do in Budapest
considering what they were doing in the countryside.
In order to try to prevent any mass killings
to happen in Budapest a group of senior Hungarian
statesmen organized a meeting with Horthy
to try to plead with him.
During the meeting, at the end of a fairly
distressing conversation in which Horthy seemed
to have continuously refuse to address the
main issue, one of the statesmen finally lost
his temper and asked plainly “If the national
army enters the capital city, will there be
a pogrom - YES or NO?” to which Horthy replied
“There will be no pogrom, but a few people
will have to take a swim.”
Despite Horthy’s not completely satisfactory
answer the meeting ended on a positive note
as the Hungarian statesmen were happy to hear
Horthy say “there will be no pogrom”.
The meeting was also a start to a series of
events which slowly lead Horthy away from
the thinking of his radical right-wing officers.
The fact that some of the most senior Hungarian
politicians were afraid of what Horthy’s
army was doing started to open Horthy’s
eyes to the idea that perhaps the White Terror
has gone too far.
He even met with the representatives of the
Jewish community of Budapest to hear their
side of the story before his takeover of the
city.
By the end of 1919 Horthy still did not completely
denounce the work of his officers and outside
of few pardons which he gave to several jews
and communists captured by his army he still
remained in silent support of the White Terror,
but over all he did start a clear slow shift
away from the radical right-wing ideas and
their proponents.
With that said, despite this “softening”
of Horthy, Gombos and other right winged officers
still saw Horthy as a strong leader and the
best bet for establishing an authoritative
nationalistic state.
Therefore, they started to organize a large
propaganda campaign, mostly headed by Gombos,
to expand the leader cult around Horthy and
to promote him as the only viable leader who
can save Hungary.
Horthy didn’t order this propaganda campaign
but he also didn’t stop it and probably
at the very least felt flattered that his
officers organized it.
The National Army marched into Budapest, with
Horthy leading it atop a white horse, 16th
of November 1919.
The pogrom in Budapest that so many were fearing
did not happen as Horthy gave clear instructions
to not repeat in Budapest that what happened
in rural Hungary.
After taking Budapest Horthy was advised by
many of his radical right-wing officers to
establish a military dictatorship and conquer
back the lost lands of Hungary.
After all, at this point he was the only man
in Hungary with an army and now even had the
capital city in his control.
Horthy, however, did not do this.
The reasons for why were multiple.
First, Horthy still saw himself as a military
man, a person who shouldn’t play a significant
part in politics and a person who should always
be loyal to his king who, at this point, still
had a chance of returning to Hungary.
Second, there was almost no chance that the
entente would tolerate an irredentist military
dictatorship in Hungary, especially not after
what happened with the communists.
Therefore, Horthy continued to play the part
of an apolitical military leader who would
support the establishment of a coalition government.
With that said, while playing this part of
an apolitical military leader, Horthy did
slowly increase his involvement in politics,
from 1919 to 1920, but largely only in support
of other politicians he agreed with rather
than as an independent figure.
With the capital now back in Hungarian control
the entente set about establishing a coalition
government combining all the various independent
counterrevolutionary administrations that
sprang up all around Hungary.
This coalition government was to oversee an
election held in January of 1920.
The election was boycotted by the social democrats
in respons to the oppressive actions against
leftist parties during the White Terror which
still continued in the coutry side.
Due to this, and the overall counter revolutionary
sentiment that spread across Hungary after
the fall of the Hungarian Soviet Republic,
the government which was elected was overwhelmingly
conservative and in favor of restoring the
monarchy.
The entente, however, at this point made it
very clear that they will not tolerate any
return of Habsburg rule in Hungary.
This meant that the overwhelmingly monarchist
government had to look for a different solution.
This different solution came in the form of
electing a regent who “could preside over
the recovery of his country and hold the reins
of power until conditions were more propitious
for Karl von Hasburg’s return.”
As for who would fill this position of a regent
there was really no question.
Sure there were more senior and higher ranking
nobles in Hungary who could be elected as
regents but Horthy’s popularity among the
people at this point was unmatched by any
other Hungarian.
Despite his hand in the White Terror he seemed
to have publicly distance himself enough from
it, while still not actively stopping it,
that by 1920 many people viewed Horthy as
the most viable candidate despite his chequered
past.
Not to mention that his radical right-wing
officers were still actively working on a
propaganda campaign around his leader cult
hoping that Horthy would eventually establish
that desired military dictatorship.
When it came to the politicians themselves,
some had gripes with Horthy.
Such as his poor skill of the Hungarian language
which was allegedly just as bad as the Hungarian
of Franz Joseph, or his poor understanding
of statecraft and politics, but, for the most
part, many still viewed Horthy as a man who
could be controlled and didn’t have large
aspirations for power.
After all he had an opportunity to establish
a military dictatorship when he took Budapest
but he didn’t.
So, when it came to the Parliamentary vote
to choose a regent, Horthy was elected in
a landslide (95%).
He, however, did something which many of the
politicians did not expect.
He refused to take the regency, stating that
he cannot accept a position which was gutted
of its function by parliament and demanded
to have more power as regent, such as the
ability to dissolve parliament.
The parliament was furious, but they also
couldn’t realistically deny Horthy’s request
as they did just elect him in an overwhelming
majority and Horthy’s loyal army officers
were currently stationed in Budapest just
in case.
Whether Horthy actually planned to have the
army officers stationed in Budapest as an
intimidation tactic or the officers were acting
of their own accord is hard to say.
In any case, parliament acquiesced to Horthy’s
demands who subsequently, on March 1st 1920,
swore an oath to protect the Hungarian people
and nation as its regent.
Now as the regent, with increased political
power, Horthy could no longer play the card
of silence and indifference.
He had to choose sides or risk losing his
position.
Therefore, harkening back to his old deeply
entrenched monarchist roots, Horthy sided
with the so-called “old conservatives”,
the monarchists of the parliament, and his
days of silently supporting the radical right-wing
army officers and politicians were coming
to an end.
This wasn’t an overnight change and it did
take more than a year to manifest but by the
end 1921 the White Terror finaly ended as
Horthy withdrew his silent support and even
enacted certain laws that would stop it.
The exact numbers of the White Terror are
impossible to determin as no real records
where kept by the perpetrators but definitely
at least 1000 (with some historians stating
more than 5000) people lost their lives with
tens of thousands (around 70,000) injured
maimed and imprisoned.
Horthy finally detached himself from the radical
right-wing officers and politicians and started
to even support some jewish and socialist
programs.
Like the governmental financial recovery plan
funded by jewish capital, or the allowing
of leftist parties to print their newspapers
which they where forced to stop during the
White Terror.
Horthy still retained some antisemtic prejudice
but no longer was he going to support active
eradication and suppression of them.
When it came to communism, Horthy also retained
a strong anti-communist sentiment for pretty
much his entire life, but again he was also
no longer going to support active killing
of communists in Hungary.
Horthy’s former radical right-wing friends
were furious with him, accusing him of becoming
“soft” a “jew loving aristocrat” a
“drugged puppet” of the “freemasons”,
they basically became the YouTube comments.
In 1923, in opposition to the old conservatives,
these right-wing radicals formed their own
party called the Racial Defense which from
its name you can probably guess what it was
about.
Thankfully it never gained much political
support but its ideas remained ever present
in Hungarian politics and strongly entrenched
in the Hungarian military.
Horthy in the early 1920s also had several
plans to reconquer primarily Transylvania
and Slovakia but these never went anywhere
as most Hungarian politicians were against
any military actions considering their neighbors
had military support from the entente and
Hungary's economic situation was very poor.
This is not to say that the Hungarian politicians
didn’t want to restore original Hungarian
borders, they just were hoping to do it diplomatically
through revising the Trianon treaty, not through
yet another war.
Plus, Hungary had one more major problem to
deal with in 1921 and that was the return
of the Habsburg king Karl the IV.
Biography of Miklós Horthy : The Return of
the King
Horthy was sporadically communicating with
Karl during the entire post war period and
during their communications he never gave
any sign that would suggest he would not give
up the throne to Karl if he returned.
Plus Horthy still saw himself as a loyal subject
of the emperor.
But, the roughly one year period of Horthy’s
regency between 1920 and 21 gave Horthy a
taste for power, for control, and for being
able to do something to help Hungary.
Horthy came to increasingly see himself as
someone who could help and fix Hungary if
only he stayed in power, and so, when, Karl
unexpectedly came to Hungary, to retake his
throne, Horthy went through a serious internal
crisis.
It also didn’t help that the Hungarian parliament
was at the time also divided between “legitimists”
supporting the return of Karl von Habsburg
and the “free-electors” supporting the
election of an official Hungarian king e.g.
Horthy.
In essence, Karl's arrival in Hungary split
both the loyalties of parliament, and of Horthy’s
conscience.
Karl, however, remained convinced that the
old admiral would keep his promise he made
to him in 1918.
Karl also allegedly secured a verbal promise
from the French prime minister that France
would support habsburg restoration in Hungary.
Armed with the belief that Horthy was going
to relinquish power to him and that the French
would support him Karl, without a large entourage
nor much planning, suddenly showed up at the
royal palace in Budapest 27th of March 1921.
Horthy was told about Karl only minutes before
his arrival and was in vivid turmoil.
One of Horthy’s bodyguards noticed this
and in the hopes of encouraging the regent
said “The Guard will be faithful until death
to the Regent.
In the name of the Magyar nation we ask the
Regent to remain true to the oath he has taken
to the nation.”
Minutes after that, Karl and Horthy were sitting
in the main office of the royal palace and,
what Horthy described as “the most difficult
moments in my entire life”, began.
Horthy admitted the throne should belong to
Karl and that he was still a loyal servant
of the emperor but, at the same time, Horthy
also believed he was a better choice to lead
the Hungarian nation at this specific time
and that, if Karl took the throne, Hungary
would be occupied on all sides by its neighbors
who were supported by the entente which already
stated it didn’t want Habsburg restoration.
Despite being a loyal servant of the emperor,
Horthy could not let this happen.
When Horthy declined to relinquish power Karl
asked “You would disobey a command of your
King?”
Horthy, clearly unnerved by this statement,
didn't reply, and continued to argue that
it was impossible for Karl to take the throne.
“There is not even a one-half percent possibility
that your Majesty will succeed.”
Brushing these arguments aside Karl continued
to question Horthy’s loyalties but the regent
would not yield.
Finally, to address the regents' concern with
the entente, Karl mentioned that he had the
support of the French prime minister but he
could not prove it for it was only given to
him verbally.
Horthy was very skeptical of this and continued
to refuse to relinquish power.
After an almost 3 hour debate Horthy concluded
with “Your Majesty, I must choose between
my loyalty to the dynasty and to my nation.
I choose the nation, and will not hand over
the government, because in twenty-four hours
this unfortunate country would be occupied
and partitioned.”
With that, the conversation ended, and a deeply
saddened Karl departed the palace, but he
did not leave Hungary.
The next day Karl sent a message to Horthy
stating “I demand that you immediately submit
yourself to my command, I have no doubts,
my dear, faithful admiral, about your response.”
Horthy responded “I cannot oppose my king
… pushed into a conflict of conscience I
shall be forced to resign: that is why I ask
for the withdrawal of this order.”
Karl, however, did not withdraw his order
and the regent did not resign.
The following days, as the word got out that
Karl was back in Hungary, the entente diplomats
in Budapest all reaffirmed they will not support
Habsburg restoration in Hungary, and the neighboring
countries, confirming Horthy’s fears, stated
that a return of a Habsburg rule would give
them a casus belli.
The alleged French support for Karl never
materialized and so even the legitimists seeing
that a peaceful restoration of the Habsburg
monarchy wouldn’t be possible started to
withdraw their support.
In the end, Karl had no choice but to leave
Hungary in April.
Horthy could finally breathe a sigh of relief,
but not for long, as Karl returned to Hungary
20th of October that same year.
This time hoping to take the throne by military
means.
This was to be the last hurrah for the remaining
Hungarian legitimists who started off in Sopron
and continued to gather supporters on their
march to Budapest.
Horthy again argued that he couldn't give
up the throne because if he did Hungary would
be destroyed in a war with the entente and
its neighbors.
Therefore, he, along with the free-electors
in the parliament, tried to quickly mobilize
a defense of the capital with Horthy proclaiming
he will defend Budapest against “our poor
king who has been led astray”.
Seeing this as a serious military threat neighboring
countries partially mobilized some of their
troops, most notably Czechoslovakia who was
poised to “exploit the crisis to deal a
crushing blow to nationalist and irredentist
sentiment in Hungary”.
The entente yet again stated their strong
opposition to any Habsburg rule in Hungary
while also denouncing the intentions of Czechoslovakia.
Karl, seeing that he had no international
support and that his restoration could spark
not just a civil war in Hungary but also an
all out war with its neighbors, finally gave
up.
He left Hungary in November for the last time,
defeated.
The free-electors now in control of the parliament
imposed their will and in November a law was
passed effectively dethroning the Habsburg
dynasty from the Hungarian throne.
Hungary still remained a kingdom, with a regent,
waiting for a king; however, now that the
habsburgs were effectively dethroned, who
was to be this king of Hungary exactly was
never determined.
This was mainly due to the fact that the old
conservative monarchist system which Horthy
and his parliament implemented, and which
did not differ much from the system of the
old empire, was keeping the status quo and
the old aristocracy intact, and so, in turn,
the old aristocracy, who was largely in charge,
did not mess with the system that kept them
in charge.
Electing Horthy as an official king might
have upset the balance in the country and
in Central Europe as a whole and so, the status
quo of having a “regent” who was effectively
the king in all but name was never changed.
Therefore, it wasn’t unsurprising when in
1929 Count Bethlen, the then prime minister
of Hungary, proclaimed that “Horthy would
remain in office to the end of his life”.
Horthy and his old conservative parliament
believed that a full democracy would be a
disaster, a rule of the mob, and so implemented
a system where only 28% of the population,
mostly the upper and upper middle class, was
eligible to vote.
This meant that old conservative parties could
remain largely in charge of the parliament
during the interwar period and the aristocracy
remained in control of most of the country's
land and industry (along with rich industrialists).
This system was called by some a “semi-feudal
order”.
Horthy, himself, was also often called having
“an almost medieval mentality” who often
revald in his leader’s cult which compared
him to such medieval Hungarian figures like
John Hunyadi.
To give an example of Horthy’s medieval
mentality; during one comedic affair, when
in 1936 some Czechoslovak newspapers published
some slednoures articles about Hungary, Horthy,
to defend his nation's honor, challenged Masaryk,
the then president of Czechoslovakia, to a
duel.
This obviously did not happen but it goes
to show that Horthy was often stuck in his
19th century ways.
With all that said, despite Horthy’s championing
of old conservatism and his dissociation with
the right-wing radicals in the early 1920s,
the undercurrent of radical right-wing movements
never really went away in Hungary.
Horthy never actually tried to stomp out the
right-wing radicals and on occasions even
tolerated their presence, especially in the
military, which proved highly problematic
by the time of the second world war.
Biography of Miklós Horthy : The Two Sides
When it came to the late 1930s Horthy was
presented with multiple, all partially unwelcome
opportunities.
He was happy seeing the rise of fascisim across
Europe which, despite not agreeing with its
values fully, he saw as a far more favorable
political movement than communism.
However, the rise of fascism in his own country
and the creation of the Arrow Cross, was a
highly unwelcomed one.
In Horthy’s eyes they were far too radical,
far too anti-semetic, and far too in favor
of a military dictatorship which would upend
the centuries old Hungarian semi-feudal order.
Horthy also had some gripes when it came to
Hitler himself, a man “whose vulgarity and
histrionic ways were hardly the marks of a
true gentleman”.
Despite all these gripes, Hitler tried to
entice Horthy by presenting him with the opportunity
to restore the original borders of Hungary.
Horthy was extremely pleased with this opportunity
but also extremely cautious.
Being an old admiral he never for a second
believed, if a world war was to break out,
that Nazy Germany could ever beat Britain
and USA who had much superior navies.
He even made this known to Hitler on multiple
occasions.
Horthy was instead hoping that if Hungary
was to restore its original borders it would
do so not just with German support but also
with allied support.
This was obviously quickly shot down by both
the allies and Nazy Germany.
With Horthy’s plan of both German and Allied
support for the restoration of Hungarian borders
not materializing.
Hungary started to be politically pulled apart.
Hungarian politics became increasingly divided
between the “German Sympathizers”, who
wanted to use an alliance with Nazy Germany
to restore Hungarian borders and defeat the
Soviets, and the Hungarian “Neutralists”
who, even though also wanting to restore Hungarian
borders, believed Nazy Germany was going to
lose the inevitable world war, and, therefore,
wanted to remain neutral waiting for a more
opportune moment for the restoration of Hungarian
borders.
Of course, there is far more to this divide
than just the way Hungarians wanted to restore
their original borders, the neutralists, who
were mostly the old conservatives, also didn’t
like the rampant German antisemitism and over
all prefered closer ties with the west.
While the German sympathizers were mostly
Hungarian fascists and other right-wing radicals
who wanted to implement many Nazy style laws
in Hungary.
To the dismay of the Hungarian fascists and
the German sympathizers Horthy sided yet again
with the old conservatives and for much of
the pre war period pursued a tactic of neutrality.
When Nazy Germany was getting ready to invade
Czechoslovakia Hitler told Horthy that if
Hungary was to aid in a possible invasion
it could take the whole of Slovakia.
Even though delighted at the prospect of this,
Horthy declined the offer, fearing that it
would force Hungary into an alliance with
the Axis who would be fighting a losing war
against the allies.
Horthy even told the British and American
ambassadors in Budapest that Hitler was a
“madman who was bringing the world to chaos.”
With all that said, Hungary did gain Southern
Slovakia thanks to the First Vienna Award
which was a conclusion to the Munich Agreement.
The Munich agreement was, however, an internationally
recognized treaty, and even though largely
negotiated by the Germans, Horthy and his
neutralist allies made sure to make it clear
that Hungary negotiated its part of the agreement
alone and not in partnership with the Nazis.
In essence Horthy and the neutralists were
using the political situation in Europe to
their benefit while keeping the Nazis at arms
lenght to secure their neutrality.
Hungary employed the same tactic, of keeping
German involvement at arms length, a couple
of months later when they annexed Ruthenia
during the German invasion of Czechia and
the proclamation of independent Slovakia.
This was met with greater international opposition
than the annexation of Southern Slovakia as
it wasn’t part of the Munich agreement but
for the most part, with Germany supporting
the action, Hungary did not see much international
backlash.
Again, just like with Southern Slovakia, Hungary
could only do this because of the actiaons
of Nazy Germany, but again, Horthy and the
neutralists only exploited the political situation
which the Nazis created, withou actually directly
working with the Nazis and sometimes even
opposing them.
This opposition can, for example, be seen
when the Nazis asked if Hungary was to help
them invade Poland or at least let German
troops travel through Hungary, to which Horthy
allegedly replied he would rather blow up
his own rail-lines than let the Germans use
them.
All this political maneuvering of Horthy and
the neutralists, of trying to keep Hungary
neutral while exploiting the situation, was
becoming ever more controversial in Hungary.
Sure Hungary did gain some land but that paled
in comparison to what it could have gotten
if it just cooperated with Germany fully,
and due to this the Hungarian fascists and
the German sympathizers were gaining ever
more power.
Plus, after the German victory in Poland and
later in western Europe, even some of the
neutralists started to doubt the neutrality
stance Hungary had taken.
Then, when Romania was weakened due to being
forced to succeed Bessarabia to the Soviets,
the largely fascist army officers in Hungary
started to pressure Horthy and the neutralists
to take Transilvania.
For now was the time, Romania was weak.
They even began to prepare the Hungarian army
for an attack.
This entire situation made Hitler furious.
He could not allow Hungary to instigate a
conflict with Romania who he viewed as a valuable
ally for a future attack on the USSR.
Therefore, he offered to arbitrate the whole
situation.
Subsequently the Second Vienna Award occurred
and Romania was forced to give up northern
Transylvania in order to appease Hungary.
Yet again were the Hungarian fascists and
German sympathizers proven correct.
If only Hungary was to just work directly
with Germany it could gain so much more.
This affair also showed that Horthy was losing
control over his ever growing radicalized
army which was the main instigator of this
entire clash.
All these events came to a head in 1941 when
Hitler effectively manipulated Horthy.
Hitler knew that Horthy, an old admiral, always
had dreams of establishing a Hungarian port.
So, playing on these dreams, Hitler proposed
that if Hungary was to help in conquering
Yugoslavia he would negotiate with the Italians
to give Hungary a port in Croatia.
Horthy was so enthused by this prospect that
he could not be stopped even by his neutralist
allies from making Hungary partake in this
war.
The old conservatives pleaded with the regent,
they tried to convince him that this was a
terrible mistake.
After all, he himself believed that Germany
could not win this world war.
However, Horthy’s military staff and other
German sympathizers argued that this was finally
the chance for Hungary to retake its southern
lands back.
To gain a port.
In the end, Horthy could not be stopped from
his dream of acquiring a port for Hungary
and so approved Hungarian involvement in the
Yugoslav war.
This meant that Hungary was to finally go
to war alongside Germany.
The Hungarian fascists and German sympathizers,
despite still being opposed by Horthy, finally
got what they wanted and enthusiastically
supported the regent’s decision.
The years of neutrality that the neutralists
have been trying to cultivate were shattered
by the fascists and Horthy’s ambition.
The prime minister of Hungary at the time,
Teleki, who was a neutralist staunchly against
siding with Germany stated that “My situation
is extremely difficult, because the regent,
the army, half of the government, and the
parliamentary majority are against me”.
He tried everything he could to keep Hungary
out of the war but in the end he failed.
This failure made him go into deep depression.
He could not bear to see his country go into
yet another world war alongside Germany which
he believed couldn’t be trusted.
Due to this he committed suicide right before
the invasion of Yugoslavia.
His suicide note read “We have become breakers
of our word - out of cowardice - in defiance
of the Treaty of eternal friendship based
on the Mohacs speech.
The nation feels this, and we have thrown
away its honor.
We have placed ourselves on the side of scoundrels,
for there is not a word of truth in the stories
of atrocities against the Magyars or the Germans
[in Yugoslavia].
We shall become the despoilers of corpses,
the most abominable of nations!
I did not restrain you [Hungary].
I am guilty.”
Horthy was shaken by Teleki’s sucide but,
nonetheless, still believed he made the right
decision.
After the successful invasion of Yugoslavia
Hungary did gain some territory from the campaign
but by far not as much as Horthy was hoping.
It was partially due to this that, when the
German invasion of the USSR began, Horthy
initially did not support it and did not declare
war on the USSR.
But, the fascist movement in Hungary was too
strong at this point and the new fascist prime
minister László Bárdossy, along with the
fascists in the military, convinced Horthy
that it would be in Hungary's best interest
to declare war against the USSR.
Convincing Horthy of this, actually, wasn’t
very hard as he was a staunch anti-communist
since the time of the Hungarian Soviet Republic
and Bárdossy presented the war to the regent
as an “old crusade against bolshevism”
which Horthy very much liked the sound of.
and so, Hungary was going to war alongside
Nazy Germany again.
Win or lose, Hungary’s fate was now unquestionably
tied to that of Nazy Germany.
Even though the fate of Hungary was now tied
to Nazi Germany, Horthy still seemed to have,
in the back of his mind, believed in the superiority
of the allied navy.
Britain had broken off diplomatic relations
with Hungary at this point but America had
not, as it wasn’t in the war yet, and Horthy
invited the American ambassador in 1941 for
friendly meals during which he would talk
to him about the “Anglo-Saxon powers”
and their navy and industry.
Horthy’s prais of the “Anglo-Saxon powers”,
while being at war with some of them, goes
to show just how much Hungary, and Horthy
himself, was politically divided.
Horthy still seemed to have garnered some
sympathies for the western allies.
On the other hand Horthy could not ignore
the very strong fascist movement in Hungary
or the fact that Hungary was in no position
to oppose Nazi Germany.
If Hungary didn’t go to war willingly with
Nazi Germany it would certainly be forced
go.
On top of that Horthy viewed the war with
the USSR as separate from the war with the
Western Powers.
In his eyes, the war against the Soviet Union
should have been supported by the west as
he was fighting against the “power that
intends to destroy civilization”.
In contrast to that, the war with the western
powers, which later also included the US,
was a misunderstanding that he hoped could
be solved with “some sort of compromise
peace”.
Therefore, when Hungary, in accordance with
Nazi Germany, declared war on the US in December
of 1941, Horthy was absolutly devasted and
furious, for he did not approve this declaration
of war and it was solely done by the prime
minister Bárdossy.
Before the departure of the US embassy from
Hungary Horthy’s son, Istvan, “expressed
the sympathy for the Allies that both he and
his father felt”.
With all that said, the initial victories
of Germany against the allies made even Horthy
start to doubt his own belief in the “Anglo-Saxon
powers” and made him, weirdly, for a brief
moment, hold contradicting beliefs in both
Axis and Western Allied victory.
When it came to the jewish question during
this time, Hungary was yet again strongly
divided.
The old conservatives, along with Horthy,
even though holding some antisemtic views
themselves, were not willing to implement
the extremely harsh anti-jewish laws of the
fascists.
Ironically the Hungarian upper house, the
Hungarian version of the house of lords, (Főrendiház,
House of Magnates), which was criticized for
keeping the “semi-feudal order” of hungary
intact during the interwar period, now thwarted
the enactment of harsh antisemtic laws by
the right-wing anti-semits in the Hungarian
lower house (Képviselőház, House of Representatives).
All of this is not to say that the parliament
did not implement antisemetic laws during
this time, it definitely did.
For example, Hungarians deported some jews
to Nazy Germany who did not have Hungarian
citizenship, they forcibly relocated or even
killed some jews living in the newly conquered
border areas to strengthen the areas “ethnic
make-up”, and they confiscated some jewish
property, etc.
But they also protected most Hungarian jews
from being deported to Nazy Germany, or being
used as forced laborers, or being killed just
for being jewish.
Most of these legislations, both good and
bad, were either signed off by Horthy or not
suspensory vetoed by him.
This quote by Horthy perhaps best summarizes
his views on the situation and the overall
sentiment of the old conservatives towards
the jews ”I have perhaps been the first
to loudly profess anti-Semetism, yet I cannot
look with indifference at the inhumanity and
senseless humiliations when we still need
them.
Moreover, I consider, for example, the Arrowcross
men [and other right-wing radicals] to be
by far more dangerous and worthless for my
country than I do the Jew.
The latter is tied to this country from self-interest,
and is more faithful to his adopted country
than the Arrowcross men, who … with their
muddled brains want to play the country into
the hands of the Germans.”
Also during this time, while the war was going
well, Horthy, after having a couple of health
scares at the age of 74, started to worry
about the succession of the regency.
He was convinced that the next regent should
be his eldest son, Istvan Horthy, who he viewed
as a genius.
It was true that his son was very knowledgeable
and had extensive managerial skills but he
also lacked any political or military skills,
plus, he was viewed by a lot of the Hungarian
politicians as a quote “liberal playboy”
who was the worst of both worlds.
The old conservatives viewed him as too liberal
and too willing to enact certain social reforms,
the socialists saw him as a conservative aristocrat,
the fascists viewed him as too socialist,
and, worst of all, he held no antisemitic
views which was unacceptable in an age of
rampant antisemitism.
Despite all this, Horthy did manage to get
his son elected in 1942, with few caveats,
as a Deputy Regent.
So, for a brief moment, the succession question
seemed to have been resolved but, that same
year, Istvan would sadly die on the eastern
front.
After Istvan’s death, Horthy’s second
eldest son, Miklos Horthy junior, became the
next candidate for the Deputy Regent position,
but considering the now ever worsening state
on the eastern front, more pressing matters
had to be attended to first.
As the war started to turn against Germany
and in doing so also against Hungary.
Horthy’s belief in the “anglo-saxon powers”
and his disdain for Nazy Germany and Hitler
returned in full force.
Horthy quickly allied himself with the neutralists
once again and started trying to regain some
favor with the allies by beginning secret
peace talks with them.
He, however, made sure to exclude the Soviet
Union from these talks.
Horthy, along with all the other Hungarian
politicians, feared that if the USSR gained
control of post war Hungary that “was bound
to mean the end of Hungary, for it was quite
natural that as a drop in the ocean of Bolshevik
and Slav peoples the Hungarian identity would
disappear.”
Therefore, Horthy tried his utmost to gain
whatever favor he could with the west, primarily
Brittain and the USA.
Britain and the US, with their preparation
for D-day, put pressure on Hungary to rebel
against German control and in doing so divert
German resources.
The allies insisted that Hungary “should
immediately follow Italy’s example (i.e.
jump out) shouldering the risks.
If Hungary failed to draw the consequences
of this situation it would mean that it was
once more siding with the Germans.
It would thereby forever lose her chance of
being handled differently from Germany by
the victors … [Hungary] should take this
step even at the risk of temporary German
occupation.”
When Horthy along with his politicians voiced
concerns of “The possible ramifications
of German invasion: the destruction of Hungarian
democratic elements and Europe’s last intact
Jewish community” the allied negotiators
replied ”there is a war on, we are up to
our necks in blood, a few hundred thousand
lives here and there will not make a difference.”
All these negotiations were caught by the
German secret service and in order to keep
Hungary loyal, and in the war, Hitler invaded
Hungary in March of 1944.
Hungary did not fight back against the Germans
as many Hungarian fascists welcomed the regime
change and Horthy knew that Hungary had no
chance of defeating the German army so he
didn’t try to fight it.
Horthy also came to a tenuous agreement with
Hitler where he will still remain in power
even if as a figurehead for the Germans.
Horthy justified his logic of staying in power,
even when controlled by Germany, thusly “I
cannot let an usurper sit in this place.
I have sworn to the country not to forsake
it.
I am still an admiral.
The captain cannot leave his sinking ship;
he must remain on the bridge to the end.
Whom will it serve if Imredy sits here?
Who will defend the army?
Who will save the million Magyar lads from
being dragged away to the Russian shambles?
Who will defend the honorable men and women
in this country who have trusted me blindly?
Who will defend the Jew or our refugees if
I leave my post?
I may not be able to defend everything, but
I believe that I can still be of great, very
great, help to our people.
I can do more than anyone else.”
Horthy seemed to have stayed true to these
words and tried to fight the best he could;
the Hungarian fascists, the Jewish deportations,
and the German control over the country.
At one point, when Romania withdrew from the
Axis in August of 1944, Horthy seized on the
opportunity of a weakened Eastern front and
tried to retake control of the Hungarian government
and also quickly signed an armistice treaty
with the Soviets.
This brief regaining of control over his country
by Horthy lasted only until October when the
Nazis, who anticipated this move by Horthy,
imprisoned him with the help of the Hungarian
fascists and, afterwards, forced him to revert
the armistice treaty with the Svoiets and
abdicate in favor of the Arrowcross.
Horthy was then, on October 17, taken to the
western train station in Budapest, along with
his family, and forced to board a train to
Germany where he would remain a prisoner for
the rest of the war.
The train which took Horthy to Germany in
1944 took the same path, in the opposite direction,
as the train which took Horthy from Vienna
to his home in Kenderes in 1918.
That October 17 1944 was to be the last time
Horthy would ever see Hungary.
For even though he survived until 1957 mostly
living in Portugal, he was never allowed to
return to Hungary because the post war government
established in Hungary viewed him “as the
incarnation of the evil against which progessive
people everywhere had to fight”.
Well, that was a long video.
Don’t forget this video is part of a greater
collaboration called Project Dictator where
various history YouTubers made videos on various
topics on dictators or on people who had been
called dictators and shouldn't have etc.
Basically we went with the most broadest definition
of the word dictator and what kind of a video
we can make about it.
So if you want to see any of those videos
click the playlist link in the top right corner
or the description or the pinned comment.
Hopefully you enjoyed the really long video
this time around, however, don’t always
expect this.
This length of a video was more of an exception
for me.
Let’s see how it’s going to do.
Hopefully well.
Hopefully this video is also monetized because
I spend so much time and money working on
it, if it’s not monetized, maybe please
consider supporting me on Patreon.
With that said, thanks to all my Patreon supporters
and special thanks to this month's deity tear
Patreon Daniel Garza.
My name is M. Laser, and as always, stick
around for history.